- Es geht jetzt hier um Folgendes:
ganz normaler Kassenvorgang.
Hier siehst du zum Beispiel, wenn
du hier anhebst, rollt das Rollband.
So. Ähm. Wir arbeiten sehr viel mit
diesem Scannercode, den du hier siehst.
Wo ist er? Da.
- Da.
- Ganz klein auf der Seite.
Ganz normal drüberziehen.
Und dann erscheint der Artikel
hier vorne auf dem Bildschirm.
- Okay.
- So. Und hier vorne haben wir diese Liste:
PLU-Liste, das bedeutet Price look-up.
Da kannst du dann schauen, wenn
der Kunde zum Beispiel eine Banane
oder mehrere Bananen drauf hat,
dann tippst du hier die Nummer ein.
Mach das grad mal. Die 4001.
- Hallo.
- 67,25 Euro bitte.
- Ja.
- Möchten Sie bar oder
mit der Karte zahlen?
- Ich zahl mit der Karte.
- Karte, okay.
War das nicht …
Wo muss ich denn da draufdrücken?
- Auf Artikel-Summe.
- Summe.
- Genau.
Und dann drückst du auf Kartenzahlung.
- Ach so.